had we all known that there was not WMD
I think that there have been certainly
less least on my part or a rush to war
our brains we really have spent most of
their time evolving on African savanna
we're becoming aware we're making small
changes we are still the only superpower
life expectance in our country 35 yes I
don't simply mean slow down aging I mean
actually rejuvenate people at the
molecular and cellular level we as
individuals are totally responsible for
what the planet will do tomorrow there's
an enormous gap with the way other
nations view the United States as to
what we stand for the international
community has a very low expectation of
African countries this eases people who
meant to survive on AIDS Guantanamo
infectious diseases when the country was
founded we had slavery which certainly
didn't include or comprehend Thomas
Jefferson statement of the Declaration
of Independence of Liberty I prefer to
be an optimist the world wants us to
regain our former stature
you